après plusieurs mois de fermeture en
raison du copic 19
le musée de la piscine de roubaix rouvre
ses portes au public un lieu
emblématique de la ville qui a marqué
plusieurs générations de roubaisiens
c'est un endroit vraiment superbe j'ai
appris à nager j'ai 33 ans dans les
années 1930 la ville de roubaix charge
l'architecte albert de construire la
plus belle piscine de france
une piscine dont les roubaisiens
profiteront jusqu'en 1985 année de sa
fermeture pour raisons de sécurité le
bâtiment pouvait toujours être visitée
mais seulement une fois par an pendant
les journées du patrimoine
et pour le conservateur des lieux pas
question d'envisager une démolition au
18ème on a démoli le ménage au 19ème on
a démoli 18e au 20e on a démoli le 19e
ont commencé à démolir le 20e et je
crois qu'il ya un juste rééquilibrage
maintenant pour sauver les bâtiments qui
sont exceptionnelles pour sauver ce
bâtiment historique
la ville décide de le transformer en
musée en 1997 les travaux commencent et
pour l'architecte jean-paul philippon la
piscine devait rester l'élément
principal du projet le bassin devient
l'espace fort de la scénographie du
musée
bon en conservant une partie en eau en
partie centrale en disposant les
sculptures retour le 20 octobre 2001
après quatre ans de travaux et
d'installation c'est le jour de
l'inauguration
l'ancienne piscine devient
officiellement le musée d'art et
d'industrie de roubaix
un nouveau lieu de vie pour les
roubaisiens qui ravit aussi quelques
souvenirs lac l'émotion qu'ils peuvent
pour un jt plus court le musée de la
piscine de roubaix fait partie des lieux
culturels les plus visités de la région
nord pas de calais juste derrière le
louvre lens
entre les mois d'octobre 2018 et 2019
environ 280 mille personnes ont visité
le musée roubaisien
[Musique]